[Music]
well charitable trolling is a it's a
passion of mine always has been it's how
i connect with
the world it's how i connect with uh
with people this is something i don't do
it for myself that's what i want people
to realize i do it i do it for others
[Music]
i of course reached out to aoc
personally both on twitter and through
email to try and coordinate with her to
make sure that the funds made it to her
abuela she had just bought a tesla
and she has uh
two houses has zumba glasses i assume so
um she just realized she didn't have it
in the budget to help her abuela and she
had to you know leave her abuela in a
dilapidated house in puerto rico uh
living in in filth and so that's when i
knew that
i had to to leap into action leave no
abuela
behind it's always been my personal
motto i wish i had known
the depths
of my own
generosity
we raised 100 000
in 10 hours
i knew i was a generous person i didn't
realize how much generosity i had in my
heart and in my soul
and so when i got into this it just
became it took over my life and just
became a passion unlike anything i
could have possibly predicted well it's
not about besting
aoc you know that's not why i do this um
it's about again helping others
the fact that i make her look stupid in
a process
is just icing on the cake but
she also makes herself look stupid all
the time so there was already icing on
the cake
and that there's more icing on top of it
there's just like a bunch of icing
on the cake
i think abuela
would probably say
she would say something i wouldn't
understand it because she doesn't speak
english but i would know
in my heart
that what she was really trying to say
was thank you
and you're a handsome
beautiful man
and i love you more than i love my
granddaughter
that's what she would say
where do you go to see walruses they're
excluded from society uh there's no
walrus representation
you walk down the street when's the last
time you saw walrus
unless you're at the women's march or
something
so she's convinced by the internet and
by society that if your child is is
identifying as something then he really
is that thing and so she tries to raise
her child as a walrus as a sort of trans
walrus i knew it would have an impact i
didn't expect i didn't realize
the extent of the impact
that it would have you don't know
anything about this book trying to do
the laws it doesn't sound like a bad
kind of book you know it sounds like a
nice little children's book but
it's not but just the other day someone
came up to me and they said uh there's
obviously someone who completed their
transition to be a walrus
i could tell just by the way they looked
and they told me how much it meant to
them and i said you know i said i and i
thanked her and i said uh well i really
appreciate it and
also i love your music luzo you know how
many fortune 500 companies are run
by trans walruses
zero
how many trans walruses
are in elected office very few
how many trans walruses are in hollywood
michael moore hasn't made a film in
years so
there's certainly a lack of
representation which i which i traced
back to bias which is why i wrote the
book
well i first learned about the trans
residential community when i when i made
it up in my head
it was an incredible moment of
self-discovery
for me when loudoun county said well you
can't speak here unless you're a
resident
and that's my first
all of a sudden kind of a huge
coincidence i heard the voice in my head
that said you're a virginian i lived in
tennessee i felt sort of like a
virginian
trapped in a tennessean's body i
identify as sort of state fluid i guess
i wanted to do something
and i was being told i couldn't do it
and then i realized that it'd be a lot
more convenient if i had this identity
that's when that's when the
confrontation happened
self-identity
can be
can be convenient and it can be
politically useful
and that's something that the lgbt
community has known for years um clearly
but it's it's
for me it was a it was kind of an
awakening moment you know my commitment
to trolling
is
is absolute i just got to explain to my
wife and kids that we're going to be
staying in someone's basement my wife's
commitment to trolling is doesn't go
quite that far so she's
not necessarily willing to move
just because it's a funny joke i've i
found out
that's part of the burden that you bear
as a trans residential
american
[Music]
what is a woman
can you tell me that you know this to me
goes back to
the point that
i don't troll
for myself i do it for others
and because of the way that i love
people
and so i realized that there are all
these women marching at the women's
march
but they don't know what a woman is they
don't know who they are they're
just wandering around
confused
you know and you can kind of you could
see that when you look at the images of
these
women just wandering around like zombies
and so i wanted to
send them a message
to help them sort of understand
themselves
well we were originally going to release
what is a woman in
may
we realize that pride month is in is
starts in june and so there's this great
trolling opportunity there
and i think talk about guinness world
records i think it's the first film
in history to have the release date
delayed purely for trolling purposes and
i'm quite
i'm quite proud of that
and so we had
the movie what is a woman coming out
which you can go to what is women.com
to find out more about that
and so i realized i wanted to make money
off of the movie
you know hopefully a lot of it
and also at
the loving people stuff too
[Music]